digamos que queremos multiplicar 5 x al
cuadrado por 3 a la quinta a que es
igual esto pausa en el vídeo y ven si
pueden razonar esto aunque sea un poco
vamos a resolverlo juntos y lo que vamos
a hacer es usar las propiedades de la
multiplicación y las propiedades de los
exponentes para reescribir esta
expresión podemos ver esto como que
estamos multiplicando muchas cosas por
lo que no importa el orden en el que las
estamos multiplicando podemos ver esto
como 5 por equis cuadrada por 3 por
equis a la quinta potencia o podemos
multiplicar primero el 5 y el 3 podemos
verlo como 5 por 3 por equis cuadrada
por equis a la quinta a que es igual 5
por 3 por si no lo saben es igual a 15 a
que es igual x cuadrada por x a la
quinta algunos de ustedes quizás ya se
hayan dado cuenta de que aquí entran en
juego las propiedades de los exponentes
porque si multiplico dos cosas así que
tienen la misma base y exponente
diferente esto va a ser igual a equis a
la y sumamos estos exponentes la
potencia 2 + 5 o la séptima potencia si
lo que acabo de hacer no les parece
familiar vamos a recordar que es x
cuadrada x
es igual a x por x ya que es igual x a
la quinta es igual a x por x por x por x
por x y si los multiplicamos todos
juntos que tenemos pues tenemos 7x que
al multiplicar las juntas nos da x a la
séptima aquí lo tenemos 5x cuadrada por
3x a la quinta es igual a 15 por x a la
séptima la clave aquí es ubicar estos
coeficientes estos números como el 5 y
el 3 los multiplicamos y luego por cada
variable que tengamos por ejemplo si
tenemos x aquí como base común podemos
sumar esos exponentes lo que acabamos de
hacer aquí se conoce como multiplicación
de mono mios lo que suena bastante
sofisticado pero este es un mono mió y
en el futuro multiplicaremos cosas como
polinomios donde tenemos múltiplos de
estas cosas sumadas entre sí pero eso es
todo lo que es multiplicar mono mios
hagamos otro ejemplo pero usamos una
variable diferente para agregar cierta
variedad
digamos que queremos multiplicar el mono
mió 3d a la séptima potencia
multiplicado por otro mono mió menos 4 t
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
muy bien vamos a hacer esto un poco más
rápido me fijo en el 3 y en el -4 los
multiplicó primero y resulten menos 12
luego multiplicó t a la séptima por t
nuevamente la variable t es la base por
lo que te a la séptima corte a la
primera potencia que es la t es igual a
t a la octava potencia o t a la 8 aquí
lo tenemos de nuevo hemos multiplicado
otro conjunto de mono mios